You're on.
ELIZABETH COOPER: OK,
good morning and welcome.
Thank you for agreeing
to meet with me to serve
on this advisory group to
develop a regional water
strategy for our
metropolitan area.
I've called this meeting to
give you my advice for how
to proceed in this process.
During this meeting, I will
first clarify our goals
in this process.
Then I did devise some
challenges that I see
and what we stand
to lose if we don't
conduct this process wisely.
Next, I'll give my
thoughts on the strategy
to follow to make a sound
and politically viable
regional plan.
And I'll talk about what I
think success in this process
would look like for you to keep
in mind prospectively as you
carry out the planning process.
So our goal is to
develop a strategy
for administering
water that balances,
and to whatever extent
possible, actually
meets the needs of the
diverse stakeholders
from the industrial,
residential, agricultural, and
conservation sectors, as well
as our partners in government.
I also believe that a
second, but still important
goal is to get through
this process in a way
that this diverse
group of stakeholders
feels good about the causes
they took part in, has learned
from it, and thus
is encouraged too
and has a skill set
to collaborate again
in the future.
As you know, we
face some challenges
to developing this plan.
With current distribution
and used water supplies
are tight and are
insufficient to meet
the needs of development that we
hope will return to our region
with economic rebound.
If we don't develop a
strategy to as far as possible
meet the needs of all the
stakeholder groups involved,
we will see rising
conflict that could really
strain the relationships
in this community
and ultimately tear it apart.
I'm also concerned that if we
don't act wisely and proceed
in a way that everyone
is on board with,
our process could be
undermined by parties
who feel disenfranchised
or who don't want
to collaborate on a solution.
So how do we navigate this
delicate task with our eyes
open to arrive at
a sound solution?
I'm very confident in
your abilities and those
of the experts that you talk
to make sound difference
about a plan to share
and distribute the water,
but I don't want to just rely on
expertise to engineer the best
solution to this problem.
I want a plan that is developed
to be the result of an informed
consensus that has the
backing of everybody
needed to implement it.
Political viability is
one key factor we need,
and an expert solution won't
necessarily get us there.
You have been
selected to be part
of this advisory group
because of your expertise
and credibility to
deal with this policy
and decision-making effort.
You have the authority to
convene a credible process.
However, I think we will end
up with a stronger and more
politically viable
solution if we directly
involve stakeholders
who we see as
likely to be in conflict over
the decision-making effort.
I suggest you bring in
a professional neutral
facilitator who can aid
in involving stakeholders
in the proposal
generating process
and who could help
solidify participants
confidence and the
neutrality of the process
since disagreements are likely
to be politically charged.
Here's how I
suggest you proceed.
Hire an experienced
neutral as I said.
Begin by conducting
situation assessment.
This means meeting with
representatives of each
of the stakeholder groups.
I previously
mentioned and anyone
else who thinks they should
be included in the process
and discuss with them what
their needs are for water, what
their interests are,
and how they'd like
to see a regional plan develop.
After you've conducted
that assessment,
distill down the
results of your research
and communicate to the public
the parameters of the problem
and what are some of the
preliminary avenues that could
be pursued to reach a plan.
Ask stakeholders groups
to select representatives
to participate in a formal
consensus building process.
Conduct joint fact
finding about uses of
and needs for water in the
region and help participants
explore strategies that
conceptualize water
as a flexible resource where
it can meet multiple groups
needs simultaneously.
Here you can bring in
your own expertise.
And by all means,
we want everyone
to agree together on
the facts that we're
going to use to make the
recommendations together.
Invent options based on the
results of the information
gathering.
Help participants
in the process.
Find ways to add value to the
resources you're dealing with
and invent mutually
acceptable solutions.
If necessary, bring other issues
besides water to the table.
These groups
intersect and overlap
in a number of areas that
affect our planning strategy.
And it might be that if we
add in other ingredients,
we're able to package
solutions that are
more acceptable to everyone.
Excuse me.
Help representatives
caucus the various options
with their constituencies
and clarify their interests
and needs and help them package
options together in a way
that everyone can agree to
and have them all endorse
an agreement for a strategy.
And then they will turn that
recommendation over to you
to formalize and then that's
what we would implement.
After we engage in this
process, how will we
know that we've succeeded?
All groups can sign
on to the agreement,
and all agree that it is a
better arrangement than having
no agreement at all.
And participating
groups will have
learned about each other's
needs and each other in a way
that they can see that
coming to consensus
is not necessarily
a zero-sum game.
I think that this is the
best strategy not only
because collaboration improves
the quality of the decision,
but it also makes it
more implementable.
It should help neutralize
the process politically
if it has extremely
widespread support.
Both the media and
the state government,
who have been less than
favorable about developing
a regional water plan would
have a hard time criticizing it
if everyone really backs it up.
This has been a brief
overview, and I'm
happy to address questions
and discuss in more detail.
Thank you.
LAWRENCE SUSSKIND: Thank you.